hey guys it's justine and today i am
unboxing some new smart luggage by
samsara and i'm so excited about this
because they just partnered with apple
to have an integrated air tag inside of
their luggage and this is incredible
because ever since the air tags first
came out i have had one on pretty much
every single thing that i own but in my
luggage i would always just kind of toss
it in and it would get mixed up and kind
of i don't want to say lost because i
can always find the air tag but it was
never in one general place and it never
really had a home a huge thank you to
samsara for partnering with me on this
video so i may have miscalculated my
desk
thinking that i could unbox this here i
i think we can do it let's lay this down
and open it up the air tag is right
there it's right there to greet us this
is incredible if you've never used an
air tag yet absolutely love them oh my
gosh it's the yellow luggage so these do
come in three different colors they have
a white a black and this yellow so
pretty and even comes with like a nice
little dust cover as well look at that
these locks are tsa compliant which
means you can keep everything in your
suitcase secure i really like that this
has an aluminum frame and it doesn't
have zippers because a lot of times
zippers are easy to tamper with the air
tag is included with your purchase of
the suitcase i'll put a link in the
description where you can get more
information about this luggage and if
you do decide to purchase one of these
smart tag suitcases make sure you use my
code i justine at checkout to receive a
packing bag worth fifty dollars let's
open it up shall we
i like that this has like an aluminum
frame around it zippers are very easily
to be tampered with this feels
industrial so this is the carry-on size
and there's also a grand carry-on that's
a little bit larger so i feel like this
is going to be perfect for short trips
and i also pack a lot of technology so
anytime i go on a trip i end up using a
full suitcase and just filling it with
gear and i already like this because
this has this separate little zipper
side here and i feel like i'm already
kind of envisioning where i'm gonna put
things i am actually going on a trip to
yosemite here very soon and i'm gonna be
packing this up and testing it out and
seeing how it works i can put all my
podcast gear here
and what's this oh my goodness there's a
whole other bag of goodies
look at that okay tsa accepted luggage
love to see it oh i also love that this
has a little strap so that i can strap
all of my clothes or gear inside of i'm
excited about what's inside of here
because they said that this also has
some little packing accessories i
love packing accessories like when i
pack i'm obsessive like i make sure
everything is perfectly organized and
then when i get to my destination it all
kind of explodes and it is an absolute
disaster but the process of getting to
my location and then even returning like
i even fold my dirty clothes in a
separate little section so that i can
have them all set and ready to do
laundry when i get back this looks like
it could be like a little
garment kind of cover to like hang up
your suit oh yeah definitely a suit or
like dresses
so this is pretty cool i actually even
like this bag too like i would use this
for something like maybe like laundry or
who knows that's nice oh we've also got
these little bags too i feel like these
would be good for shoes bathing suits
because i like to keep everything
completely separate like i said like i
don't just put everything in everything
has a special place and i like that
these have some additional little bags
oh my gosh even a little toiletry bag
and it all matches
check that out
i love like these little yellow accents
this is a really cool bag too this i
would probably use for like shoes and i
also like that this has a reinforced bag
so i feel like this is definitely
something that i would use shoes for in
my mind also thinking about packing gear
i always like to have my lenses wrapped
in something so this has this extra
little protection here so i could wrap
my lenses up in that my camera lenses
that is oh my gosh and there's a second
one this one doesn't have the reinforced
bottom but it is like the same size what
is this little guy
look at this this is like a little
duffel bag
how great
another one
one
two
three
nine
like we got nine little extra bags that
came inside of here like this just folds
up it's like basically nothing in there
i'm such a fan of tiny bags now the real
highlight of this luggage is yes it is
incredible the quality is awesome i love
these zippers everything feels like very
premium but it comes with an air tag
there it is
an air tag many of you have seen these
before
no way look it has their little logo on
it so now let's set up the air tag it's
great because all you really have to do
with these is bring it close to your
phone and hit connect i definitely
recommend setting up this air tag before
you decide to put it inside of your
luggage it's all set up let's
take a look
see how this goes in here this just
opens up just like so
and then this lifts up
it has a clear little window right here
and we just pop in our air tag
air tag is in and we're gonna close this
little lid and screw this back on
it's so great i love it like this
doesn't even look like an air tag it
just looks like it's their logo
how awesome now that we have this all
unboxed i'm gonna pack it up and we're
gonna see how everything fits
i guess
[Music]
oh
so i brought my luggage to yosemite this
is exciting this is the first time i've
actually used it and i've been using it
as a gear luggage storage so i pretty
much have everything in here that i need
my cameras my lenses i even have an
extra pair of shoes in here right now
and all of my podcasting equipment which
is amazing because everything fit in
here and i love the fact that it is a
hard-shelled case because everything is
nice safely and secure inside but the
other thing that of course is the
highlight for this is it has an
integrated air tag in it and it looks so
cool
and the fact that it has their logo on
it no one's gonna know they're gonna
think this is just a little piece of
like a logo so i actually didn't know
you did it no i didn't know that wasn't
it i know it's an air tag it's pretty
cool i know it's great
if you're familiar with air tags there's
a lot of different things that it can do
obviously you can play a sound so that
you can locate your item or there's just
the find my and because it connects to
bluetooth you can also use the option
where you can walk around and try to
find it so as you can see here it says
three feet nearby and as i get closer to
it
it says
here i just i died pretty great
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching hope
you guys enjoyed this video and again
the link will be in the description and
be sure to use ijustine at checkout i'll
see you guys in the next video bye
[Music]
[Applause]